[Música]
Hola soy Marina sardiña y les doy la
bienvenida a Expreso de oriente El
magacín quincenal de France 24 en el que
les acercamos las historias de medio
oriente América Latina Esto es lo que
veremos hoy terminó en jenning la
operación militar israelí denominada
caza y jardín mientras Israel amenaza
con nuevos ataques y los palestinos
entierran a sus muertos tenemos análisis
desde el terreno Y esta semana se cumple
una década del golpe de estado militar
en Egipto que alzó al poder al Mariscal
abdel fatal City el país está sumido en
una crisis económica y de derechos
iniciamos en el campo de refugiados de
llenín que durante dos días sufrió el
episodio de violencia más intenso desde
la segunda intifada con bombardeos con
drones y ataques por tierra que dejan al
menos 12 muertos y cientos de heridos
así como miles de desplazados a muchos
le trajo el amargo recuerdo de la naka
catástrofe de 1948 cuando miles de
palestinos fueron desplazados por las
milicias sionistas para dar paso a la
creación de Israel yenines hogar de unos
14.000 palestinos y es también el
símbolo de la resistencia Armada
Palestina contra la ocupación ilegal de
cisjordania para analizar esto
conectamos con Federico cué Barberena
corresponsal de France 24 en Israel y
los territorios palestinos Federico lo
primero como escaló la violencia en
yening y cuál es el contexto de estos
últimos días
fueron menos de 48 horas en las que duró
esta operación israelí en yin por tierra
y aire la masa grande desde la segunda
intifada en la combinación de soldados
en el terreno y ataques aéreos con
drones no tripulados causó la muerte de
12 palestinos o cuatro de ellos menores
de edad así como la de un soldado
israelí además 740 heridos y una amplia
destrucción en la infraestructura Civil
del campo Israel celebró su campaña que
según el ejército le permitió incautar a
gran cantidad de armas y desmantelar
decenas de instalaciones de la brigada
de jenning el grupo armado que opera
allí desde hace poco más de un año y que
reúne a milicianos de todas las
facciones palestinas en su mayoría
jóvenes pese a esto entre los palestinos
del campo reina ya terminada la campaña
una combinación de enojo y triunfo
porque entienden que la operación de
Israel no ha quebrado el carácter de
llenín como bastión de resistencia
Israel ha dejado Claro que más
operaciones de esta envergadura son
probables en el futuro y el Primer
Ministro Benjamín atañaju ha reafirmado
en sus palabras una nueva era en la
lucha contra el terrorismo en la que los
ataques aéreos acompañarán a las
habituales enredadas como siempre la
violencia engendra violencia y aunque no
ha habido una respuesta grande ni
organizada de las milicias palestinas en
Más allá de las del lanzamiento de
algunos cohetes desde casa si se están
produciendo ataques palestinos
individuales como un atropellamiento
entre David que causó diez heridos y un
tiroteo cerca de nablus en sí Jordania
ocupada que ocasionó la muerte de un
hombre israelí como decías Federico
Israel ha destruido buena parte de la
infraestructura del campamento de
refugiados y también las ongs han
denunciado que se impidió el paso de
ambulancias y de asistencia médica Cuál
es la situación humanitaria en yening la
situación es de devastación como lo han
advertido agencias de la ONU y
organizaciones no gubernamentales que
trabajan en yin aproximadamente unas 800
casas han sido dañadas o destruidas
caminos enteros se fueron arrasados o
por el paso de las aplanadoras israelíes
y de a poco se trabaja para restaurar la
luz y el agua que fueron cortados en
casi todo el campamento donde también se
hizo visible la falta de medicina y
alimentos en una de las áreas con más
pobreza y desempleo de todas y Jordania
ocupada en la agencia de la ONU para los
refugiados palestinos por ejemplo debió
suspender sus servicios y sufrió daños
en un centro de salud y una carretera
que conecta con una de sus escuelas
emiratos árabes Unidos es uno de los
primeros en moverse para ayudar a la
recuperación del campo y anunció una
donación de 15 millones de dólares otro
gran impacto fue el de los de los
desplazamientos internos con entre 3000
y 4.000 personas esforzadas a salir del
campo para escapar de los combates y
resguardarse en refugios o viviendas
familiares algunos de ellos comenzaron a
regresar tras la operación israelí y lo
que encontraron fue solo destrucción
Muchísimas gracias Federico Seguiremos
pendiente de la situación en yening
por su parte Israel alego que la
incursión en yening responde a una
campaña para eliminar a los combatientes
palestinos el Primer Ministro israelí
Benjamín tanyahu se refirió al fin de lo
que denominó una acción integral contra
el enclave terrorista amenazando también
con llevar a cabo nuevas acciones Esto
es lo que dijo
Esta es una señal de nuestros próximos
pasos esto es solo el primer paso no es
de ninguna manera la última acción que
tomaremos haremos lo que podamos desde
Tierra desde aire con una inteligencia
excelente haremos lo que podamos para
luchar contra los terroristas No tendrán
Refugio seguro
y seguimos en jennin para analizar el
ataque de mayor envergadura desde la
segunda intifada de 2000 a 2005 y para
ello nos acompaña Mohamed a marcha
especialista de comunicación para el
medio al shabaka wamen Muchas gracias
por estar con nosotros Nosotros venimos
advirtiendo en este programa y
analizando esta escalada de violencia
que no veíamos Algo similar como
decíamos desde la segunda intifada que
se viene ahora para los palestinos del
campo de refugiados que muchos han
retornado a estos hogares en ruinas y
cuál es el contexto histórico en este
lugar de resistencia Palestina
Gracias por tenerme en tu programa
primero y
quiero decir que en los últimos días los
palestinos del campo de la verdad han
vivido una segunda Nava la palabra árabe
que significa la catástrofe de proceso
de expulsión de más de
70.000
700 mil palestinos en el año 48 cuando
se fundió el estado israelí lo que ha
pasado en estos últimos días confirma
también que la sigue y continúa para los
palestinos y que los refugiados fueron
sometidos Porque el campo de geninín
tiene miles y miles de refugiados desde
el año y generaciones de refugiados
desde el año 48 y ahora fueron sometidos
otra vez de nuevo a la condición de
refugiado después de ser expulsados de
nuevo
también hay que reconocer que el régimen
israelí está cambiando su estrategia en
sijis Jordania junín y su gente enfrenta
lo mismo destino de gaza y como teníamos
como enclave
terrorista
y su campo por ejemplo están rodeados en
cada entrada con Checkpoints cuentos de
control militares ahí como también hacen
en casa las fuerzas israelí utiliza
bloqueos económicos militares contra la
jubilación ahí perfila la ciudad con
drones todos los días y usa la práctica
de castigo colectivo como hemos visto
esta vez y en operaciones anteriores
contra la población ahora los palestinos
del campo Los espero a un futuro En mi
opinión más oscuro con el régimen
israelí avanzando estas estrategias y
estas medidas pero también me parece que
el sentido de comunidad de solidaridad
ha ganado en genil he visto muchos
en redes sociales
de
solidaridad de desde toda Palestina de
Los palestinos
en los territorios 48 y también
palestinos afuera de Palestina y también
mucha gente en la región invitó a los
segundos refugiados
ofreció sus casas hasta que termine la
operación Pero la verdad no sabemos cómo
me parece que el futuro es oscuro para
la gente de genil pero la resistencia
sigue sigue viva
y usted cree que Israel logró sus
objetivos En yin cuál era el propósito
de esta nueva campaña militar
la verdad es que tenemos que entender
que genin en los últimos 20 años
ha convertido en en un nuevo modelo de
resistencia Armada insis Jordania contra
ambos la ocupación y colonialismo
israelí en todos los territorios
ocupados y también contra la autoridad
Palestina y su complicidad en la
ocupación en varias veces en el pasado
la autoridad Palestina como entidad que
trabaja para la ocupación
intentó poner fin al movimiento de la
resistencia Armada ahí en la ciudad pero
no no lo ha logrado y se ha logrado
fracasó en hacerlo así que régimen
israelí ahora ha lanzado varias
operaciones en los últimos años para
acabar con la resistencia armada de una
vez para siempre en porque no quieren
que lo reproduzcan en otros ciudades en
sisjordania Y creo que eso fue el
objetivo de la operación y de las de las
operaciones que vienen en el futuro creo
que Israel no lo ha logrado todavía pero
no va a ser la última vez de este tipo
de operaciones Y quién brinda apoyo a
los grupos armados militarmente en la
cisjordania ocupada Y por qué cada vez
más jóvenes deciden enrolarse a sus
filas cree que veremos nuevos ataques de
las milicias palestinas también en
respuesta a esta incursión de las
fuerzas israelías
primero es que oficialmente los grupos
armados no están afiliado oficialmente
con los partidos tradicionales en
Palestina son más como colectivos de
resistencia armada de jóvenes
decepcionados con las políticas y
estrategias de los partidos
oficiales y de la autoridad Palestina y
de Los Linares oficiales
desde desde los acuerdos de oslo estos
jóvenes vienen de familias de refugiadas
que siguen contándoles las historias de
su expulsión y de ahí estos jóvenes
entienden que en los últimos 75 años
no han logrado nada nada ha cambiado
para ellos no han logrado un estado
soberano ni autodeterminación ni sus
derechos humanos ni civiles y después la
segunda enchufadada la destrucción total
de la ciudad y la abandono autoridad
Palestina los jóvenes no pueden ya
aguantar el sistema de ocupación y
colonialismo que cada día empeora y
agrada sienten que la única forma de
vivir es resistir en todas las formas
violenta y no violenta porque no hay
otra manera para liberarse Hay que
luchar y por eso creo que va a seguir la
resistencia
y va a avanzar en otras ciudades en
cisjordania
Muchísimas gracias por habernos hecho
este análisis tan completo aquí en
France 24
Gracias por tenerme
nosotros terminamos en Egipto porque el
tres de Julio se cumplieron diez años
desde el golpe de estado del entonces
Mariscal abdel fatal Sí sí que terminó
con el derrocamiento del expresidente
islamista Mohamed morci veamos esta
historia de nuestro equipo de France 24
en el terreno
en este mercado Popular en el centro del
Cairo al igual que en el resto de Egipto
el precio de los alimentos ha aumentado
un 60% en un año este vendedor de ganado
del Sur del país lo sabe de primera mano
el precio por kilo eran 80 libras Y este
año son 150 es más del doble de lo que
costaba el año pasado hace 10 años
cuando la crisis económica afectó el
país aumentó el descontento político los
egipcios salieron a las calles para
protestar contra su primer presidente
elegido democráticamente el islamista
Mohamed morci el ministro de defensa de
esa época abdel fatal Sisi tomó el poder
por la fuerza declarando que la
hermandad musulmana era una organización
terrorista y no permitió que nadie
cuestionara Su autoridad
un proceso en el que se reescribieron
las leyes del país para incorporar todos
los elementos de la autoritarismo del
abuso y de las prácticas extra legales a
un año de las elecciones presidenciales
la oposición es inexistente entre tanto
los egipcios se preguntan Cómo harán
para seguir alimentándose llegamos así
al final de esta edición de Expreso de
oriente Muchas gracias por acompañarnos
y sigan con más información en France
24.com
[Música]